you can easily lose sight of the loss
here
of the lives buried beneath
the crops the homes
the hope
we're in the catcher area of dadu in
sindh province
a window into a community
that's drowning in change
this is normally completely dry and look
at it now it's the lake and in some
places
it's 20 feet deep and there are whole
villages
completely submerged
[Music]
stranded standing on what little land is
left
these are the people of jan muhammad
huddled together
here for three weeks
with no access to aid
clinging on to
no one came here to help thank goodness
i got my children here but they have
fevers and stomach
this has become an island and they are
among the most vulnerable there's about
100 people living here lots of them
children many of them sick they are
desperate to leave but they're worried
there's just no shelter and no food for
them anywhere else
[Music]
it's cramped
space and sanitation and short supply
and so is medicine with disease
spreading
[Music]
this boy has spots all over his body his
mother believes it's caused by the flood
water
they're exhausted but the water is
rising and it's a risk staying put many
of the children in this area are already
malnourished
[Music]
grandson
is three months old he has a fever
it could be very hard days ahead
[Music]
while they fight for survival their
education is on hold
this is the local school
and they've lost their places of prayer
too
where they walk was once a road and they
can't see a way out
this is being called a climate hotspot
the victim of a world that's playing
catch-up
cordelia lynch sky news sin province
pakistan